مخاوف مقلقة الليلة من
ارتفاع فيروسات التاجية في الولايات المتحدة
حطمت كارولينا الشمالية رقمها القياسي في
عدد حالات دخول
المستشفيات إلى ما يقرب من 800 الآن حيث أظهرت 18 ولاية أخرى
قفزات في الحالات.  يقول أنتوني فوسي
إن الأمر لم ينته الآن ، لدينا
شيء اتضح بالفعل أنه
أسوأ كابوس لي وهو شيء قابل
للانتقال إلى حد كبير في فترة ما إذا
فكرت فيه في فترة أربعة
أشهر فقد دمر العالم
ولم يعد كذلك.  انتهى الأمر حتى الآن ، لذا فإن أي سلافيت موجود هنا
لمناقشة أندي هو المدير السابق بالنيابة
لمراكز
الرعاية الصحية والخدمات الطبية
.  من
الواضح أن أنتوني فالتشي لم ينته بعد مع رؤية العديد من
الولايات لهذه الارتفاعات مقارنة
بالأسبوع الماضي ، هل تعتقد أن الأمريكيين
يتخلون عن
حذرهم ويحتاجون إلى أن يكونوا أكثر يقظة على ما أعتقد ، لذلك أعتقد
أننا يجب أن نتذكر أنه لم يحدث شيء سحري
عندما  بقينا في المنزل ، لقد كانت
تضحية كبيرة وأعلم أنه بالنسبة للكثير من
الناس شعروا أنهم لم يكونوا متأكدين
مما حدث قليلاً ولكن هناك بعض الدراسات التي تم
إجراؤها الآن والتي أظهرت أنه في جميع أنحاء
العالم كانوا مئات الآلاف إلى
ملايين الأشخاص الذين  إما أن يتم
إنقاذ الأرواح أو تأخر المرض ، ولكن هذا
هو الشيء الأساسي هو أنه بمجرد عودتنا
إذا عدنا لتحديد عاداتهم القديمة
، سينتشر ذلك بالسرعة نفسها ، لذا
يتعين علينا الخروج واتخاذ هذا النوع من
الاحتياطات التي تعتبر احتياطات آمنة
يمكننا العودة إلى الحياة الطبيعية ونرى أنه يمكننا التعايش
مع فيروسه ، لكنني هنا في المكان
الذي تربى فيه مثل أريزونا ، نورث كارولينا ،
أركنساس ، يجب أن أكون حذرًا للغاية